[Music]
all right many big races happening
around the country tomorrow night but
all eyes will be on the Commonwealth of
Virginia and of course the legislative
elections and what many are saying may
be a preview of what happens a year from
now in November 2024 there are multiple
competitive races in both the state
house and the state senate which
Republicans are hoping to flip red also
in play Governor Glenn yunin secure your
vote initiative encouraging Republicans
and conservatives to vote early vote by
mail overcome your reluctance and
resistance and do it yunan is now hoping
that this effort can serve as a
blueprint not only for the future of
Virginia elections but also Nationwide I
couldn't agree with the more here with
an update on what we might expect
tomorrow night Virginia governor Glenn y
he brings a crowd too everyone's
bringing a crowd tonight I'm the only
one without a crowd tonight Governor
good to see you
sir Sean great to be with you I have got
the next generation of generation Joshua
with me these are great
kids Future Leaders they have been out
knocking doors all over Lowden County
and that's where we are today where it
all started the parents matter movement
started in Lowden County it spread
across the Commonwealth of Virginia
Across the Nation and let me tell you
Sean in Virginia parents still matter we
have a chance tomorrow to elect Juan
Pablo sigura as the state senator from
Lowden County and the entire Lowden
County School Board is on the ballot
tomorrow and this is what voters get to
go make a statement about that they're
tired of being left in the dark they're
tired of having the school board hide
from them sexual assaults in schools and
overdoses in their schools and they're
going to make a change and that's what's
on the ballot and I am so excited to see
Virginia come out to vote Republicans
get out and vote tomorrow we have to
have you at the polls so that we can
hold our house and flip our Senate let
me let me ask ask you how your SEC
secure your vote initiative has worked
here you have a five vote uh margin
majority in the house of delegates a
five vote deficit in the Senate and
Governor I've been applauding you and
I've been telling the Republican party
they need to do this they they've
started their own initiative Bank your
vote but they also need to follow
through with another initiative which is
legal ballot harvesting which Democrats
are doing in many states again legal um
how do you feel that the effort went
leading into tomorrow which is usually
election day tends to favor Republican
voters more not sure why but you tried
to blunt the the 100,000 or 500,000
deficits that sometimes Republicans go
into on Election
Day yeah Sean in in 2021 there were
500,000 people that voted for our great
lieutenant governor winon Sears and our
great attorney general Jason mies and me
that did not vote in the 2022
Congressional midterms
500,000 so we went to work to get
Republicans off the sidelines I can tell
you that it has worked we have seen
really strong early voting turnout
particularly in our Battleground
districts like here in Lowden County
like in Prince William County with our
candidate Bill wolf like in
Fredericksburg with our count with our
candidate Tara Durant we need to get
people off the sidelines and to vote but
we got to finish the work tomorrow we've
got to get everybody who didn't vote
early out tomorrow we do expect to win
election day but we need to show up
strong in order to hold our house and
flip our Senate we have done Yan's work
over the last 22 months in Virginia
we've taken a state that was way down in
job growth bottom third we've turned it
into number three in the nation in job
growth in 22 months 230,000 more
Virginia working today than just 22
months ago when we started we have
backed the blue and we've seen law
enforcement coming back to the job and
we have stood up for parent parents and
for excellence in education this is what
voters are concerned about that's why we
got to get them out tomorrow we can hold
our house we can flip our Senate but
I'll tell you the road to the majority
in our Senate comes through Lowden
County with Juan Pablo sigura we've got
to get him elected tomorrow and I'm
asking all Republicans get off the couch
tomorrow go vote do not leave your vote
in your pocket we need you at the polls
Governor how do you feel the effort that
you've been leading has has worked
leading into tomorrow do you feel like
it's been
successful I do think it's been
successful Sean we have seen a a an out
an out registration from Republicans
versus Democrats they started with a
much higher block than us we've closed
the Gap we have had a much greater
turnout in early voting that has been
awesome and I see huge momentum across
the Commonwealth Sean I've done a 100
campaign events and I've had a chance to
talk to voters all over the Commonwealth
and I hear over and over and over again
that they love the fact that we have
provided $5 billion doar of tax relief
we recognize it's their money not
governments we've brought down the cost
of living we have stood up for parents
we have worked hard to make sure law
enforcement knows that we back the blue
these are the keys to making sure that
more people move to Virginia than move
away and we've seen that for the first
time in the Commonwealth of Virginia in
10 years here's a chance for us to take
a state that was truly lost just 20 24
months ago controlled by democrats
turning it into California and we have
taken a hard right turn and tomorrow
we've got to finish the work by turning
out the vote everybody come vote and
let's hold our house flip our Senate and
demonstrate to the nation that we can in
fact take a state that was lost and show
that she's found Governor I'm going to
be honest I was one of those Skeptics I
prior to your Victory uh just a couple
of years ago I thought Virginia was a
deep blue State you proved me wrong in a
good way and we wish you uh a lot of
luck tomorrow uh I hope the people of
the Commonwealth hear you loud and clear
tomorrow it's game on this is an
important uh race for the legislature in
Virginia thank you sir appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else